How you doing, Alexander?
>> Hello. Hello.
>> Hi.
>> Hey, great to hear from you.
>> Can you hear me?
>> Yes.
>> Hear you loud and clear. Can you hear
us?
>> Great. Great. Great. Perfect. Excellent.
>> All right. Just want to make sure that
we have everything set up here. Uh,
Professor Jen, should I have the uh the
document you sent me earlier?
>> Yes. Yes, that is uh Professor Dubin's
uh PowerPoint and I think it'd be a good
framework for discussion.
>> Okay. Uh do you think that it's worth
screen sharing or privately looking at
it?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I mean I I think
what we should do is maybe go point by
point, slide by slide because um it's
very um I mean it's very broad and I
have some I have certain questions for
Professor Dugan
>> uh in his PBT. Okay. So it is up to you
to decide. I just I just have sensed
that in order to uh show a kind of
context of approach to the end time
problem in four different traditions in
uh dispensationalism, Protestant,
American uh in Zionist, in Shia and
Islamic in general and in Russian
Orthodox. So it could be of use or maybe
not. So it is up to you to to decide how
use it. You we can show that we can we
cannot show that. So it's up to you if
it will be useful. We could uh uh make
appeal to this slides.
>> Okay, let me try to bring it on the
Zoom. I've haven't done this before. Um,
yeah, I I looked got the chance to look
through it yesterday. I thought it's uh
it's a pretty straightforward document
and I think it has a good frame of
discussion here. So, yeah, absolutely.
And once again, I want to thank you both
for taking the time to come on here
today. I I greatly appreciate this.
There's been a lot of anticipation for
this stream and I'm sure it's going to
be an interesting conversation. Thanks
so much for coming on.
Well, well, thanks so much for hosting.
>> Thank you. Thank you very much for
inviting us and proposing your platform
for this discussion. So, I'm at your
disposal. So, I have uh the pair of
hours dedicated totally to that maybe
more if it is possible. So, it is
unlimited on my side, I would say.
>> Okay, sounds great.
And I want to see side by side. I think
I'm trying to share it with uh so that
we could see also the cameras. Can you
are you able to see it or
>> Yes, I am see I myself also
>> um my screen.
Oh, here we go. I could see it like
this.
All right.
So, let's start this discussion with
this PowerPoint here. So, it's uh it
seems like it covers a lot of the basics
of esquetology.
And this is something that I I'm Muslim
so this is pretty standard for us to all
know but this is something that
professor Jang has detailed extensively
throughout his lectures and I think that
he shows the similarities and the
overlapping themes and different fates
in esquetology but also the major
differences and how you can pinpoint
what's happening in the world
geopolitically and see that there's an
overarching
theme and that it all goes back to
esqueological
beliefs.
Correct.
>> Yes. Um so I would also make the point
that um you know so I really got into
geopolitics and esquetology because I
read uh professor Dugan's book um the
foundations of geopolitics which I
highly recommend. I I I think it is the
most important geopolitical book uh in
our modern era. And the thing to
understand about esquetology is that
behind esquetology is also national
character. Um the soul of a nation and
that's why esquetology is so important
because esquetology is just the
expression of your national soul.
>> Okay. Do you have major disagreements?
And well, first off, how how well do you
know each other?
>> It's our first time.
>> Okay.
So, can I ask you uh Alexander Dugan or
if I'll just call you Professor Dugan,
what is your analysis of Professor Jen's
lectures and what do you think he gets
correct and incorrect with esquetology?
So first of all I have many Chinese
friends in China huge amount of friends
and when I have spoken when I was
speaking to them I have remarked that
almost nobody nobody knew anything about
esquetology. Uh so that Chinese culture
is very particular in my opin in my
opinion it is very balanced the
confusionist the balance between male
and female between uh in young. So that
is the harmony that prevails. So it is
not about time, not about history, not
about final combat, final battle, but
more more than that about how we need to
to make things to be very very in
peaceful way in uh in a harmony. And my
very very good friends in China, they
always ask me what is going on in the
Middle East? What is about this Zionism?
Why there is so important to have
greater Israel? Why it's so important to
to be dispensationalist in Protestant
circles in evangelicals?
So or and as well they didn't understand
Russian Cathiconic idea of our
esquetology. And after that after having
very good and friendful uh discussions
with with my Chinese friends I have on
it seems that it was on your your stream
uh snearked
the unique Chinese man who uh um had has
shown the very deep understanding of
esquetology of this end time concept,
the context of Judaism, of Zionism
and the Shia and Islamic tradition. And
I was very very astonished because in my
in my opinion that was the first and
maybe unique Chinese scholar of such
serious level who
easily easily
unders understands this very special
special subject of world politics and I
I was very very glad and now now I'm
very happy to speak with unique Chinese
scholar who has shown such deep
engagement in in the study uh studies of
esquetology. So first of all, so for for
example, nobody nobody or very few
people speaks today about Sabati
um Jacob Labor Frank about this kind of
esqueological
cabala of Natan of Gaza and this
metaphysical vision of uh cabalistic
esquetology and how it resonates, how it
it is reflected on the modern days
global politics and geopolitics. So,
professor Jang Jang is the unique it is
exception uh above there are some people
in Russia who understand that not not
many but there are but absolutely nobody
in China. So that I was very very uh
very interested and and I I have I have
seen I have watched many many other
videos about predictions about uh uh
game theory uh about as well about um
Greek uh antiquity because I have made
also my classes dedicated to the
classical tragedy tragedy of ancient
Greeks. So I was very very astonished by
the similarity of many points, many
approaches and the depth of the
knowledge of professor Jang uh about the
things that most mostly
Chinese scholars ignore or could not
could not grasp. Maybe they lack the
majority lack this this radical feeling
of the end of something of some
irreversible something linear the linear
time irreversible fight between good and
evil it is everything it is not to to
Chinese so but we are living in the
world with China cosmos China Chinese
universe and other universe universe
American universe
Islamic universe universe Russian
universe. So in order to to to
understand better each other, we need to
get deep in the respective traditions.
Maybe these traditions could be close to
us or far from us, but we we should pay
pay some efforts to understand better
each other.
>> Absolutely. And well, I I have a couple
questions for you, Alexander. I wanted
to figure out more about your belief
system because I saw some people are
reporting that you have esoteric
traditions or some are saying that
you're Orthodox Christian. It's hard to
pinpoint exactly what it is. So in in
your own words, what would you classify
your belief system is? And before you
answer, people are asking in the chat
what esquetology is. Uh maybe professor
Jen could quickly describe it the best
way but I would just say end times
philosophy
>> right so um es esquetology comes from
the Greek word escaton which means the
end. So the word literally means the
study of the end and what esquetology uh
often refers to is each uh rel religious
tradition's understanding of the end
point of history. Why are we here? where
we going um where do we come from? And
the idea of esquetology is to figure out
the point at which God um and man
reunifies which which brings about the
end end of history. So so that's the u
general idea.
>> Okay. And obviously Professor Jen is I
don't want to mclassify your belief
system but last time we spoke a little
bit about narcissism. I saw recently on
the Patrick David show, you said at the
end that you pray to God. So I would
maybe say that it's general narcissism
but not specific to one theology. Is
that correct?
>> Yeah. So for most of my life um I'm
atheist in China as is an atheist
society. I didn't go grow up with any uh
atheist tradition. Uh so I I didn't go
up with any religious tradition and
quite honestly um I've had um I was very
skeptical towards religion all my life
especially towards Christianity. Um but
these past two years because I've been
uh deep in the study of esquetology the
cabala um um geopolitics
I'm starting to develop a more gnostic
framework but I would not say that I
have one religious loyalty.
I could find a similarity. I think
learning more about Epstein back in 2019
helped steer me in the direction of
trying to find some sense of good
because there's so much evil and you
obviously Alexander Dugan just spelled
out uh how you speak about sabotage Zevy
which is not often mentioned. This is
what point to be in the direction to
look into faith. But can I can I ask you
specifically, Professor Dugan? So what
would you classify your faith as?
So first of all I'm uh I'm Christian
Orthodox. So I'm Orthodox Christian and
that defines
in what I believe. That is my
confession. That is my church. That is
my religious doctrine doctrine and
everything I could say outside of the
context. It is about studies. It is not
about recognition of my own faith. My
own personal uh and Russian faith is
precisely Christian Orthodox religion.
So I believe it is the only truth. So in
that sense I'm believer normal Christian
Orthodox believer but at the same time
I'm very interested by different other
spiritual spiritual uh tradition and in
that sense philosophically
philosophically I am traditionalist what
means to be traditionalist so I am
following the spiritual philosophy of
reneon
uh who converted into Islam that is
French great French philosopher uh and
his his disciples for example Julius Eva
and the many other titus bark uh fit of
shu and the other this philosophical
approach
uh considers the modernity to be
anti-tradition so modern world it is not
just development not just progress but
quite opposite that is decline that is a
fall. And this traditionalist philosophy
could be applied to Islam as in the case
of Genanon himself, to Confucianism, to
toism, to Christianity as was the case
of many of his disciples, Jean BS and
many other and myself in the case of
Christian Orthodox Church. But as well I
have met for example some people uh
among Jews
Judaic JIC cabalist cabalists who
followed ganon followed ginon. So you
could be ginonian to in different in
different religions. You could disagree
uh with some political or esqueological
precisely issues. But uh the main the
main thing we share all the
traditionalists we share this refusal of
the western modernity. So we can accept
different traditions but we consider the
modernity to be absolutely wrong. Right?
athism, impalism, progressism, uh
enlightenment, all that things are
totally totally evil. So that but uh
trying to to uh develop my own
understanding of what are different
traditions different than mine than
Christian Orthodox. I have studied as
well the Cababala, the Judaism, Islam,
Shia,
um, Visharak tradition, Christianity of
Catholicism, of Protestantism and many
other Hinduism for example, Buddhism and
Confucianism and Towism all that
agnosticism including some counter
tradition, counterpiritual
uh forms of tradition, all that uh is u
the part of this study but my confession
my my my only position uh as believer so
I believe in absolute truth of Christian
orthodox doctrine
>> right I think you you gave a good segue
for what I can relate to what's happened
recently I'm sure Professor Jang you saw
this as well so yesterday was Orthodox
Easter if I'm not mistaken I think the
week before was Catholic Easter and
Donald Trump recently posted well
something interesting on both Sundays.
On Easter Sunday he said praise be to
Allah. Open up the effing straight. This
is on Catholic Easter. And then
yesterday first he posts a long
paragraph about the pope. And he says
the pope is very weak on crime. This is
not a joke. He says the pope is weak on
crime. And then afterwards he posts an
AI image of himself with his face on
Jesus and he's putting his hand on what
looks like a to me it looked like
Jeffrey Epstein and in the back there's
it looks like a Roman god Libertas the
Statue of Liberty goddess. Some people
are saying that that's Malok flying in
the sky and that was also altered. My
point is when I announced this stream
speaking with Professor Jen and
Alexander Dugan, to be perfectly honest,
it went all over Twitter and people were
saying Sneo is speaking to a CCP
propagandist and a KGB propagandist.
He's speaking to China and Russian
spies. And they started saying who here
they are to talk about how Western
values are decaying. And I thought,
okay, well, they're going to criticize
this. They're going to say that there
shouldn't be some sort of foreign
influence. Well, our entire political
lobby has been infiltrated by Zionists.
Very clearly, everybody, it seems like,
has dual allegiance to Israel, first
off. So, there's foreign influence
everywhere. Second off, what exactly are
Western American values? How could that
be described? Alexander Dugan, you, I
think, accurately described it and you
spoke to what a lot of people are
feeling right now, and that the modern
Western values that we see, a lot of
people are becoming disillusioned with.
A lot of people are not happy with what
they see. And if that is described by
what we see in Euphoria, the new TV
show, Sydney Sweeney dressed up like a
baby, you know, doing this weird fetish
thing. Not to make it too disgusting
early, but what we see everywhere that's
promoted in the media and even from our
politicians, the leader of the free
world, the commander-in-chief of our
military, depicting himself as what
Christians believe to be God. This is
not what so many people want to sign up
to follow. What do you think are the
main causes of the problems we see with
American western values right now? Maybe
we could start with uh Professor Jen.
>> Right. So um um I think the root of the
problem
is 1694 because that is when the Bank of
England was first chartered. and the
bank of England. The idea was that it
would take transnational capital and um
lend it to the nation state of England
with parliament as the guaranter. Okay.
So, previously if if you were a king and
you wanted to fight a war, you need to
hire mercenaries. So, you borrow money
from merchants uh who lent you gold in
order to finance the war. The problem
with this is that the king may die, you
may lose the war, or the king may reign
neck on the contract. So there's high
risk for merchants to work with kings.
So the bank of England solved this
problem because now Dutch merchants
could lend money to England and it would
be guaranteed by parliament, the nation
state. And this was a revolution um in
European affairs because now England
basically had infinite financing. It
could fight a war against someone like
Napoleon and keep on fighting until uh
Napoleon was finally defeated. So it
took six seven wars seven wars for
Napoleon to be defeated by the British.
Um and the British lost six of these
wars. So that's the power of infinite
financing created by the Bank of
England. It basically created the the
British Empire. But how do you go about
just justifying to people? Why are you a
citizen of England um borrowing money
from these transnational capitalists,
these merchants, and if you can't pay it
back, your your son, your children, your
grandchildren have to have to pay it
back. Bas basically, your entire society
is indebted to these merchants from
overseas who you don't know. And so they
needed to create a system, a philos
philosophical system in order to justify
this. And this is this this is when you
have the beginning of what we call
modern um British enlightenment
civilization. Okay, starting with John
Lock and the um sanctification of
private property as the highest good as
something that is god-given private
property, right? Then you have people
like David Hume which questions the very
legitimacy of human intuition and and
the project of philosophy of the pursuit
of truth. And you have people like
Jeremy Bentham which put utilitarianism
as the as the heart and center of
society. If something is if something
brings people pleasure, it is
fundamentally good. Something brings
people pain, it is fundamentally evil.
And this this is the beginning of what
we call a consumer society, right? Where
each individual is seeking his or her
own uh pleasure. Then you have people
like John Su Mill who would take
utilitarianism and then create a liberal
society uh based on these principles.
Okay. So um and then from that you have
Charles Darwin u history of evolution
and Karl Marx um and and so um and and
and so these philosophers together
create the the framework for western
civilization and everything that comes
afterwards is a byproduct of this
philosophy and
professor Dugan um um elaborate if he
wants
So I agree with this
could as well we could continue that
Spencer social derminism continuation of
this Anglo-Saxon liberalism
and enrant enrant was already the kind
of of capitalist satanism. So from enant
to abstain is only one step because uh
if you have all the pleasure the other
the poor will have all the pain. So you
should be happy when the other are
essentially unhappy. So that is atlas
shr precisely the main main message of
so-called objectivism that is
finalization of this capitalist logic
but I would start a little before with
Calvinism for example and Calvinism I
think that was uh very special very
non-Christian idea affirming that there
is not afterlife that the judgment of
God is realized already in this life and
to be rich it is the sign of chooseness.
So you are you are chosen. So you are
rich and you are poor you are damned. So
Orthodox Christianity absolutely
deny that Christian Orthodox
Christianity
affirm that it is not important to be
poor or rich in this world. You should
be good. You should behave with love,
with compassion, with empathy to to the
other people and you will be judged
afterward uh afterwards when Jesus will
come again second coming of Jesus and he
will judge uh he will judge uh everybody
after resurrection. So it is the uh the
present earthly life is just a small
small infinity small part of the real
life of the immortal soul that is normal
Christian attitude and Calvinism was
total total denial of of this attitudes
everything the god uh has knowledge of
everything until the end. So he could
not make uh he could not make uh error
mistakes. So if you are rich you are
chosen you are you are blessed with with
the richness that is the the kind of
theology the the theology of the
capitalism and I think that Max Weber
has shown that in his sociological
framework and Wner Zomber has developed
that. So that is the huge tradition not
necessarily Marxist tradition but
conservative tradition to criticize
this Calvinist foundations
of the modern uh Anglo-Saxon capitalism,
liberalism, individualism and that is
the problem with United States because
when you are in United States and when
you want sincerely to return to the
traditional values you have nothing but
the founder fathers who were Calvinists.
So Mayflower was the group of of
Calvinists
um fleeing from church of England from
uh Anglican church in order to to create
totally different kind of culture of
society in the new world. So that is the
problem. So for example, you personally
or some other people if you choose
tradition of Islam. So you have the
sacred roots. If you choose Catholicism
maybe affected by modernity but not
totally modern as Protestantism. And
when you are evangelical or Mormon or
dispensationalist,
you are obliged to create something
imaginary, something completely out of
the real relations to the foundations of
the ancient roots of Christianity or uh
so you you lack the sacred roots. So
because the sacred roots of American
civilization belong to the Europe belong
to the pre pre-colonizational
uh time to middle ages and it is very
difficult to restore this link you have
mentioned for example libertas statue
but that is uh heata he the great great
goddess of the hell uh of the ancient
Greeks why she uh has a torch because
she rules in eternal night. You you you
have not uh you you have not uh any
necess necessity to have the char torch
in hand in the daylight. It is the the
goddess of of the hell of the night and
that was more or less the origins of
American civilization. So it is it is a
problem. So it is not easy to present
day American conservatives who are very
critical and that is we could understand
it very well with modernity with this
abstain class with this usurppation of
the democracy or this falsehood all that
but when you want when you try to get
back to your roots to your sources
welcome to the Calvinist heretic
group of the founding fathers of some
mercenary some radicalism of of the
sects extremist sects they were not
Zionist. Z Christian Zionism started
precisely in the time of radical
enlightenment in in the Holland and D
among the Dutch uh and after that they
that came to to to England and was
Puritans and radical Protestants after
that these uh Christian Zionism
immigrated to United States. So after
that that were the scaffold bible
dispensationalism
uh ple of brethren and so on. So it is
not traditional it is a kind of
esqueological heresy and that is the
problem metaphysical problem of American
people. So when you try to get to the
roots
your roots are rotten from the very
beginning. So and that demands to to
make some extravagant choices for you to
to join Catholicism, to join Islam, to
join maybe Orthodox Church. So many one
of the most most venerable
representative of 20 20th century
Orthodox saintthood is American is
Saraphim Rose. He was natural naturally
born naturally born American with no
tradition and he has chosen uh Christian
Russian Christian Orthodox church and he
became almost a saint for us. We uh that
is the cult of him. We considered this
American 20th century American modern
man. we consider the archetype the
example of the sanctity of holiness of
in our Christian Orthodox church. So but
that as well is a kind of limitation for
American choice. So you you are obliged
somehow to to embrace something that
could appear to be not not too
traditional for your society or Hinduism
or Buddhism or Islam. So uh but when you
start to to to to to
become American traditionalist, you are
either Mormon or dispensationalists or
Christian Zionist or Calvinist and
everything that is really really
traditional Islam, Orthodoxy or
Catholicism
becomes a kind of enemy. And now we see
uh around President Trump precisely this
fight against everything that still is
traditional in United States. So uh that
is the problem. I I'm not absolutely
malane. It is not about about mock at
American people but that is strategy
strategy and I think we we we we feel
the great contempt for American people
because they became a kind of hostages
of this historical social economical
theology or hostages of this specially
and very very heretic I would say
esquetology
Right. That makes me understand your
idea and and how you can relate
traditionalism to your theology which
you stated earlier. But so what's the
solution? You also said that you think
American tradition is rotten to the
core. And I don't want to believe that.
I love this country. I don't want to
think that it's all doom and gloom. We
got to provide some hope. But now
learning more about what the evangelical
sect of Protestantism believes and the
fact that they get subverted so easily
with this megaurch culture that you can
see epic fury and unconditional
surrender these giant posters and it
gets subverted by these preachers who
are clearly in it just for money. I
could say it's the Erica Kirk
phenomenon, right? Mostly the boomer
class who is the majority of the voting
block in America. They attend these sort
of major stadium like rituals and they
all vote for the same neocons, the same
evangelicals, the same people which you
rightly pointed out believe in the
Scoffield Bible which uh professor Dugan
when was the Scoffield Bible written.
So uh Scopy Bible that is a kind of uh
commentary of very small uh small uh
sect uh founded of Plymouth brothers
founded by
British Protestants and the commentary
very very new and very uh very uh
particular sectarian commentaries are
embedded in in the text of Bible. So
when you read the Bible, you could not
make great difference between the real
holy scripture and this modern
commentaries uh explaining that the end
fate of the humanity will be uh will be
played in the Israel and the Jews will
will return to their fatherland and all
western Christianity um Protestant
Christianity
should uh defend Jews representing
different different faith uh hoping they
will convert in the end time into the
Christianity and that is why it is
necessary fight against the Gawk Gawk
was considered to be Russian Empire
after that Soviet Union now the Putin's
Russia so Gawk is always situated in
Eurasia uh and identified with Russia
and uh helped to Jews to destroy
Amalecch and Amalcch was the traditional
uh enemy of Jewish people before Christ
and it its image is applied to the
Islamic world. So the the the fight
against Russians and Muslims become in
this Scoffield Bible a kind of religious
duty of all Christians. So that is the
total total reduction of the holy
scriptures by small and not so much
known sect. But when it was this
scoffled Bible was distributed among
American population this difference very
few people could make
very few people could distinguish
between the authentic authentic biblical
text and this embedded so-called pseudo
prophecy inside.
>> So I I looked it up. It's 1909 it was
created and you were mentioning Gaga
Magog which is a similarity in
Christianity to Islam in basic
esquetology. Do you agree because it is
speculated where this will be where
these two nations will actually be.
Professor Jen speculates that the third
Rome is in Moscow but what would you
classify as Gog and Magog? Professor
Jen.
Well, I mean um um so first of all um I
want to point out that there were three
major events that led to Christian
Zionism, right? So 1899 is when Theodor
Herszel wrote his book Junalan um
calling for uh a Jewish state. Uh then
1909 is a Scoffield Bible and in 1914 I
believe was the Bour Declaration. Okay.
So this all all these things happened
very quickly basically with the span of
like 10 to 20 years. Um so so I also
want to um um um go back to Professor
Dugan's point about Calvinism
>> because Calvinism is still in America
but it's called like the gospel of
wealth um as practiced by people like
Paula White who is the spiritual adviser
to Donald Trump. Okay. So Calvinism is
still very much alive and powerful in uh
America. And if you look at Calvinism,
um the underlying emotions driving
Calvinism are fear and anxiety. And this
and as professor Dugen go mentions this
goes against the traditional religious
practice of of other traditions where
emphasis is on harmony, on balance, on
happiness, on your relationship with
God. And now Calvinism because
communism, it's really about fear and
anxiety. So another way of saying this
is that the underlying emotions of
America are fear and anxiety. And you
can see that in in American society
today where even though America is the
wealthiest society ever in human
history, um an average like an average
middle-ass American lives better than a
Roman emperor and yet America is still
one of the most depressed societies in
human history, one of the most um
medicated um and the mo one of the most
polarized. So um if you really want to
transform America, you have to go to the
at the root of what's causing this fear
anxiety which is um as professor Dugan
points out it is basically the Calvinist
tradition. And so um if America is to uh
redeem itself or America is to become
stronger then it needs to go back to
Christianity and reexamine
um it the basic principles by by which
America is is um is built. But to answer
your your your question, what is what is
Gog and Magog? What what seems um um
from what's happening and I think
Professor Dugan would agree with me is
that Gaga Magog is being interpreted as
Persia and Russia.
>> Okay. So they will inevitably
fight in the near future and sometimes
you speculate that it's around 200
years. Uh I mean it's it's still
undetermined and we can't figure that
out completely. So is it safe to say,
Professor Jen, that Christian Zionism or
even on a broader scale, evangelical
Christianity is just a tool of Zionism?
Um well well you could also make the
argument that Zionism is a tool of
Christian Zionist. Um so what I think
happened was that these societies
Freemasons
uh were infiltrated by Cabalis. So
basically something Frankus and then
this created Christian Zionism which
then in order to um achieve its
esquetology created Zionism um um which
uh so basically sponsored the hersel's
um book. So the herself was not a
well-known person. He was a journalist
in Germany but he had access to British
royalty. And so I I I think that's
actually the chain of chain of events
you have. You have the sepatine Frankus.
Then you have the Freemasons which then
became infiltrated by the um Franks
which created Christian Zionism and then
Christian Zionism went on to conquer
America or the founding fathers were
were Freemasons
um and capitalists and then um
eventually you had the creation of
Zionism.
>> There was something really interesting I
saw yesterday. I saw these Chinese
children speaking to a western
journalist and they were asking him, "Do
Americans eat people?" Because we heard
that Epstein eats people in America. So,
it's funny that the stereotype for so
long, you know, I'm half Filipino
myself. We grew up hearing from
Americans that Asians eat dogs and now
we're hearing Chinese children say
Americans eat people.
I'm wondering what the similarities are,
what the ideas in China are about
Zionism, but also what's the ideas about
Zionism in Russia. I want to ask you,
Alexander Dugan, it's very different. It
seems like from an American perspective.
It seems like Russians have a separate
relationship and Putin is not as clear
from what I understand and it doesn't
seem like the same problem. Also, you
have different Bolevik history. What's
the Russian relationship with Zionism?
So first of all when we we speak about
Christian Zionism, Jewish Zionism, we
need as well to to to
mention so-called suda suda messiahs of
Jewish history starting from
and this sabat
Frank and interesting that
the Christian Zionism the in the
earliest stage age what was before uh
Nelson Derby and Plymouth Plymouth
Brethren
but that was started with the so-called
fifth monarchism
and that was idea that the traditional
Rome is over and there is the fifth
global empire and Oliver Cromwell
was considered to be this global emperor
by this fifth monarchist around him. At
the same time, Manasse Ben Israel, the
Jewish Rabbi, Rabbi in Dutch, uh he has
said that that was not Anglo-Saxon uh
global empire but fifth monarchy will be
Jewish when the Jews of all the world
will come to the Palestine and they will
establish this uh uh global global
empire. That is precisely the first
version of modern days Netanyahu
Ben
or or Smidge Ben Smidge the greater
Israel. So that was planned in the same
time in the 17th century precisely in
the Amsterdam around the Dutch Dutch
Protestants and from this circle uh John
Loach has taken many his inspiration. So
so every everything is um is linked
there. But I think that concerning
Russian Orthodox Church, Russian
Orthodox Church has nothing comparable
with Christian Zionism of Protestantism.
We uh we are not against uh Judaism but
we consider that very special very
separate branch of of of the uh of the
faith different totally and uh there are
so many many texts of Russian elders,
Christian authorities, Christian
Orthodox authorities they prevented that
the antichrist will come from Judaism.
So they will be a a ragged people uh
trying to impose their global global
rule and they will be antichrists and so
the more or less the same uh was cons
concerning concerning
Christian Zionist and Protestants or
Calvinists. So we uh uh never um Russian
traditional Christian Orthodox Russian
never considered
um Judaism as a lie or Jews to be today
after Christ chosen people. They were
and we we
affirm that um they
uh they were uh the
chosen people and that was true.
But when Christ came he has accepted all
the other all the other people embraced
them and it is new Israel. New Israel is
Christian church. So after that the
chosen one are all the humanity all the
people uh who uh who who should accept
the knowledge the new uh news the good
news of of Christ and the small group of
Jews who still uh insist now uh insist
on on their chooseness they are a kind
of matrix of antichrist
So that is our traditional religion
religious
general attitude. So I think that Putin
is very pragmatic. Stalin was communist.
He he was not Christian believer. So he
considered that Israel modern days
Israel could be a kind of tool to
promote socialism and communism in the
Middle East. After that that wasn't the
case. And the Juda uh Jewish state the
Israel uh has changed uh this relation
and adher to the capitalist camp and
after that started some ideological
ideological tension between Soviet Union
and Israel but no theological basis was
then and Putin is pragmatic leader. He
is considered by us by Christian
Orthodox as uh very special historic
person that embodied the cataconic
function. So idea to to keep uh to be
the keeper in the front of antichrist.
We project on him this uh our Christian
esqueological orthodox orthodox vision
but uh he behaves uh much more on the
pragmatic he is political realist. So we
have not until now the direct
confrontation confrontation with Israel.
that Judaism is considered as in Iran
the traditional belief traditional faith
uh in Russia with zero zero pressure. So
that was as minority faith that is
guarded by by the state. But I what I
could assure you that neither Putin nor
Russian government nor Russian society
has any any
feature
similar to the Christian Zionism. It is
about realism. It is about respect to
the different faiths. Uh and we see now
that geopolitically Israel becomes more
and more aggressive element to destroy
our allies to undermine the harmony and
the peace in the Middle East. But we
blame much more American hgemony than uh
than Zionism. But now this collusion,
this collusion between Christian Zionism
of Trump with its aggressivity, with
this hegemony, with this imperialism,
with this radical anti-Christian
elements you have mentioned and
collusion with this radical aggressive
uh Jewish uh Israeli Zionism that uh is
seen by our society as the confirmation
of the fears and predictions of our
elders uh Christian alto orthodox elders
because it uh becomes more and more it
looks like antich antichrist including
this posting of Trump or this
sacrilegious affirmation this idea that
Trump is god Trump is pope Trump is
saint and his uh refuse to swear on the
bible on the second presidential term.
So, so many elements now
show that we are dealing with some
esqueological
um moment in in the history. Not we
don't want that. We we don't insist on
that. Putin prefers to understand their
political reality in geopolitical
realist realist terms. But we could
could not prevent to see behind these
events the very alternative scenario. So
this is a opportunity to see if there's
some back and forth here between you
two. Uh Professor Jen, I don't know if
you've heard about Professor Dugan's
theory on the Eurasia unity. Is this
something that Chinese people are aware
of or speak about? Do you think that
there are similarities between the two
nations and something that there could
be unity on?
>> Right. So an alternative to um American
hijgemony is maybe Eurasian unity right
especially between Russia, China and
Iran. So if these three nations are able
to create a trade block um with bricks
as a framework then this could easily
extend to Europe to Africa uh to the
rest of Southeast Asia and in this um
formulation there would be no one great
power right China talks about the goal
corridor which is this um blockchain
like um goldbased financial system where
um gold is stored in different vaults
across Eurasia
and this becomes the basis of a new
financial system and this is all
plausible um and um and I think this
could be very good. The problem is that
um this would basically bankrupt America
because America is a financial Ponzi
scheme. It's $39 trillion in debt and if
people stop buying US treasuries then
America would collapse. there would be
absolutely nowhere to finance the $39
trillion debt. Um you would have
economic collapse uh civil war and um so
America right now is basically fighting
for its life in Iran. So you can make
the argument that America has no choice
but to fight this war in Iran to prevent
uh a Eurasian movement from arising.
>> I liked the theory. Obviously, I don't
think you believe it because Trump seems
like he's going through some sort of
manic episode or demonic possession
right now, but there's some theory that
it's a 5D chess move and he's fighting
this war in Iran specifically to push
the focus from the Middle East and
getting oil through the straight of form
moves into the Western Hemisphere and
relying upon oil from Venezuela or
Canada. And this is why he's trying to,
you know, he wants to invade Greenland
and and he's going to block the trade
routes and the sea routes so the focus
can now be here where we have more
protection because America, we're here
surrounded by the Pacific Ocean and the
Atlantic Ocean. Is there some sort of
basis in that claim? Because I think
Alexander Dugan follows the belief that
the Ukraine war was you were a massive
supporter of this war but also I've seen
in your lecture, Professor Jen, that the
Ukraine war was beneficial for Russia's
economy. They got to strengthen their
military and because so much military
equipment has been produced, they get to
make a lot of money and overall
Russia benefited greatly.
So um I've made the argument that um
Trump does have a plan and basically
it's it should create something called
the greater North America which is
something that Peter Hexf has also
talked about where America has control
over um Greenland, Canada, Mexico,
Venezuela, Colombia, uh Cuba, uh
Nicaragua, Honduras. Um and because
greater North America u is so wealthy
and it's so huge basically basically
becomes a continental fortress and it's
allowed to trade its resources with the
with the rest of the world. Um and this
will allow America to sustain its 39
trill trillion dollar debt. They call
this a techmate. Um um and and and this
makes a lot of sense uh geopolitically.
You basically go and destroy the GCC uh
Qatar, Saudi Arabia. um which which
fuels Europe and East Asia. They don't
they no longer have access to oil but
their entire economies are based on
cheap energy and so they're now forced
to pivot to North America which is the
only supplier now that the entire Middle
East is in flames. What's also been
happening is that the American Navy has
been targeting um Russian shadow fleet
tankers. So basically committing acts of
piracy. There was uh about a week ago a
Ukrainian drone strike on a Russian oil
pot which basically took about 40% of
Russian oil exports offline. So, you can
make the argument that even though Trump
is um crazy and he's stupid, there are
people um there are people um behind him
who understand how geopolitics works and
they're trying to transition America
from a financial empire into a resource
empire. Um but uh but but then the
question then is how will the rest of
the world uh respond? Because because
imagine a situation where America it is
in greater North America. It's a
fortress. It's safe. And America is
conducting all these wars overseas to
destabilize the world to force the world
to become dependent on American energy,
American financing, American
armoraments. And so the question then is
how would the world respond in such a
scenario? And in the short term, I think
it's impossible for the world to
respond. But maybe in the midterm, in
the long term, the world would be forced
to coalesce um maybe around Russia and
China in order to counter greater North
America. So, but but um but I'd be
interested in hearing um Professor
Dugan's perspective,
>> please.
>> So, um it is difficult to judge uh where
uh Trump's madness stops and some
rationale appears. So I could not I
could not be expert in that. So he seems
to be very special psychologically.
Uh and at the same time we could maybe
we couldn't
grasp some hidden uh second plan
scenario scenario behind uh his
behavior. So uh I think that maybe Trump
was chosen as very specific psych
psychological person by some western
deeper state, not just liberal globalist
deep state but deeper state who wanted
to use this radical tools
uh to rearrange
the falling domination of the west with
drastic radical measures And after that
to say, "Oh, you are scapegoat. You're
your family, your MAGA group. We we will
destroy all kill all of you. We put you
in prison for life sentences." But the
the the situation will be changed
already. So maybe it is uh some some
special kind of weapon, secret weapon of
hyper globalists, not just liberal
globalist, but ticknate. Exactly.
something that consider to walk
globalistic agenda as some some obstacle
as we see in Peter the or um Karp Alex
Karp technological republic this ideas
so enough with the humanitarian
uh hypocrisy let's pre represent the
power as such the nude naked western
power hijgemony
domination in open open style and uh
Trump fits very well to that. So he is
obviously mad. So everybody could say oh
no this madman has has done that but
without return to the previous pre
premadness conditions everything will be
done by this special uh persons and he
will be brutally sacrificed uh
sacrificed with all his people maybe
with including with Israel. Uh I I see
that uh some Israelis they try to find
the a plan B for them for an urgent time
from in in different places. They uh um
now they are buying the territories in
order to to to secure some safe safe
territory if they will be obliged to
flee from the Palestine. So I don't I I
think that is is possible possible
solution of all that. But uh with this
radical and metag aggression of Trump
maybe the the uh deeper state deeper not
deeper state wants to secure it's to
prolong its hegemony. Exactly. to
securing access to oil, the burning
Middle East, destroying the um context
and ties with between Russia and Europe,
between Russia and China to to to create
a kind of global war and after that puts
Trump out with
everybody around him and that could be
uh the kind of rationale
That could be plan plan B or fourth
fourth dimensional um
checkmate. So some uh something
like that. Uh but I think that it is
possible and maybe it is so but uh maybe
Trump understands what role he plays.
Maybe not. But that doesn't matter. So
maybe he's just brutally used in order
to to make a kind of radical effort to
secure
western hegemony uh more so avoid this
direct fall confronting with
multipolarity
uh multipolar worlds emerging with more
and more power uh power power and I
think that today it is very important
how we react how the world react how
American people react because some power
when in the shadow just uses you just
you uses American people, American
hopes, American beliefs, American
desires in order to sacrifice all that
to some some radical vision of abstain
type of elite. And when they say they
eat children, it seems to be not
mythology, not conspiracy theory, some
some text, some coding words in Epstein
files, they they are testimony of of
this terrible terrible state of mind and
psychology of the liberal western
post-liberal
uh post liberal western elite and
concern
concerning Ukraine uh professor uh is
totally correct. Uh this war helped to
us to resenter our economy to place the
major attention to the sovereignty to to
our our industry and we are that is
resurrection of Russian technological
sovereignty. It is not easy because we
we were part of the global economy and
now we are obliged to concentrate on our
own uh resources and that gave that that
gave and gives is giving now the new new
chances to to Russia. We're becoming
stronger and stronger and stronger and I
think that we need to uh to to pay more
attention to to the humanity because we
are not alone. We Russians, we are not
alone in this world. There is China,
there is Iran, there is Islamic world.
There is western people who are hostages
in this uh very cruel cruel game. So I
think that we need to explain to the
other our moto behavior. So we are not
anymore uh imperialist. We don't want to
occupy neither Europe nor Asia. We are
satisfied with our own zone of influence
in Eurasia and we are ready to accept
the other polls not only Chinese poll,
Indian poll, Islamic pole but we we are
ready to accept the great and
fundamental western pole and we could
treat it with respect
but we deny one thing the supremacy of
of the west. So hegemony. So the the the
world is not anymore uniolar.
And if someone in the west could accept
multipolarity, it immediately becomes
from the enemy or fool and becomes the
the partner, ally or friend. And we
Putin for example and we Russians we did
see that in Trump in the first term and
the second more than that we believed
Trump in Trump we we we heard his
strategy her slogans and we are almost
happy with that. So let let America let
United States the United States
concentrate on the western hemisphere.
Let solve its inner problem. If you uh
uh you have enough with liberals,
transgenders,
uh illegal immigration, you are right.
We could support that. That is that is
correct. But when uh Trump started to
say that there is no abstain
list, there is a hoax, when he started
to betray his own most most loyal most
loyal friends and supporters, and when
he started the new wars uh with Iran,
with Venezuela, with Kuban, when he
started to support the genocide of Gaza
by Netan Yahoo. I think we have revised
our attitude to Trump and he didn't stop
finally the support for Ukrainian
regime. He promised that but he didn't
uh do that.
>> Right. So I want to ask the both of you.
I'll start with Professor Jen. So you
you were mentioning the deep state. So
essentially your belief is that Trump is
and this is hardly a conspiracy that he
is being controlled by different forces
and he's being used as a tool to push an
agenda that's against America's
interest. So right now we are back in
the war. The ceasefire talks failed in
Islamabad, Pakistan. JD Vance, the vice
president was there, but behind him was
Jared Kushner and Steve Wickoff. These
are real estate moguls. So you keep
saying the deep state is controlling
Trump. Is it just simply the Chabbad
Lubovich sect? Because Kushner has no
position in the White House. He's not
part of this administration yet. He is
one of the lead negotiators in the
Middle East with the Gaza peace talks.
And here he is in Pakistan right next to
JD Vance. And the theory is that we were
pulled back into this war and the
ceasefire talks failed because Israel
wants to continue bombing Lebanon.
Professor Jang, is the deep state simply
just Shabbad Lubovich?
>> Right. So I think rather than say um
there's one group of people pulling the
strings, I think it's just better to say
that there's a convergence of interest.
meaning that you have different
political factions who need Trump to
start a war against Iran and Shabbat
Lubarovich are the useful idiots or the
scapegoats that can be put out front in
order to um attract people's attention
while the more powerful people are
working behind the scenes manipulating
scenes um manipulating things behind uh
the scenes. So uh you think about Jared
Kushner if he if he were really powerful
he would not be in front of the
television cameras taking all the blame
for the failed negotiation failed
negotiations not just in Ukraine but
also in Iran and in Gaza as well. It
seems to me that Trump,
Kushner, Wickov, Shabbat Luovich, all
these people are being set up as
scapegoats as Professor Dugan um pointed
out and who these people behind the
scenes truly are. Um it's really hard to
say it's the Epstein class, but but I
really think it's a convergence of
interests, right? Right. So you have the
military-industrial complex, you have
the national security apparatus, you
have secret societies like the
Freemasons, the Rosa Cruian, Knights
Templars. Um you have Wall Street and
City of London. Basically, it's in a lot
of people's interest to have this war in
uh Iran. It's really a question of like
who's going to do the work, right? Who's
who's going to be the vanguard and who's
going to be the scapegoat? And so the
people we're seeing right now are just
the vanguard, the scapegoats.
So, Professor Dugan, what is the
relationship that Russia has with
Chabbad Lubovich?
>> So, we consider that as a religious
group. We have uh two currents in in
Russia, traditional Jews and this kidic
hassidic um current. So uh our
government could not say you are right
and you are wrong because it is we could
not judge the the contradictions in the
uh Jewish community and because uh
movement is is very active uh
precisely uh they represent one part
part of religious Judaism accepted as
tradition. traditional branch of
religion of minority and traditional
Jews
they represent the the other part. So
they have uh contradictions concerning
possibility to teach the cabala cabala
to not old Talmudic persons. So they
disagree about that because Lubaiers
they they pretend that everybody should
could every Jew not everybody every Jew
could no kabala including the women and
young people and that was strongly
strongly prohibited in traditional
Judaism. So uh Russian uh Russian
government accept both uh both Jewish
sect as a part or occurrence of
tradition and nothing more. So uh the
absolute majority of Russians are
Christian Orthodox and between holy
patriarch Suru and Mr. Putin there are
relations as symphony. Symphony that is
Bzantine concept uh developed of
Eustinian emperor Eustinian that there
are distribution of power between
imperial head emperor Sar Caesar and uh
great grand patriarch that is not just
religion that is more than religion that
is kind of political theology and that
is accepted somehow
in Russia. So other minorities as Islam
or Judaism or Buddhism including
different small small uh confessions
they are accept traditional only
traditional traditional uh confessions
traditional traditional religions are
accepted but they don't play any
political role. So they uh their their
power is limited to their respective
communities and lubaiers they exist in
that they suffer no no pressure neither
political nor social. So they are
totally free as all other
representatives of traditional
confessions in traditional religions in
Russia. So when they say that Putin is
manipulated by them that that
>> totally totally totally fake fake news.
So Putin is motivated by interests of
Russia. He is Christian Orthodox. That's
very important. He is not just the head
of the state with the majority of
Orthodox Christians but he himself is
practicizing Christian Orthodox. So he
is a member of the Christian Orthodox
faith and church and he has very
balanced and very positive, very
respectful relations to uh all kinds of
other traditional religions.
>> Right. So I was watching your 60 Minutes
interview and they were calling you and
many articles say this that you are one
of Putin's spokespersons and you're
basically like the intelligence in his
ear.
One thing I respect greatly about Putin
is you can see him hold the Quran and he
kissed the Quran. And on the Eid prayer,
there are massive amounts of Muslims in
Russia who are going out to pray. And
the relationship that Islam has in
Russia is completely different from the
relationship that the United States has
with Islam. In fact, we often blame
Islam for all the problems. We accuse
Muslims of terrorism. And pretty much
every accusation that Muslims are the
victim of, it seems like Israel is
responsible for the exact same actions.
But I'm also hearing that there's
pictures of Putin and some Chabbad
Lubovich rabbis if I'm not mistaken.
It's a multi-part question, but so
you're saying that he is not manipulated
and that he has a strong relationship
with Orthodox Christianity. What is the
overall Russian perception of Putin's
relationship with Zionism? And why do
you think that Islam is more it seems
like from the outside in that Islam is
more widely accepted in Russia than it
is in America even though Russia is far
more Christian?
>> So first of all we need to make a a kind
of difference because the Muslim
population we have in Russia they were
Muslim from uh from old age. So they
were the members of our society of our
country and they didn't come from
outside. They are our own Russian
Muslims. So they were they were they
lived here in Russia for ages and they
were the part of our our our society our
state uh for a long time. So they are
Russian first and Muslim second. So they
consider uh this loyalty to to the
Russia as their the part of their their
identity. So they were not brought or
converted. So they are normal Russian
Muslims living here that is their
motherland their fatherland Russia and
they are loyal patriots an absolute
majority. They they represent second
second religion in Russia and we respect
them very much and that is uh they fight
for Russian interests in in Ukraine. For
example, my chichenians, Chichanian
friends uh uh they they fight better
than anybody else. So they defend the
holy mother Russia being Muslims be
being totally involved in their
religion not abdicating nothing making
their prayers and including u following
their religious law but they consider
themselves to be the loyal loyal
patriots and citizens of Russia
spiritual citizens not only only
political. So that is a big difference.
So uh we have so we we have no reason to
hate Islam nor neither inside of Russia
nor outside. The most Islamic countries
outside of Russia are our uh political
allies or or neutral. So we have no
Islamic country that professes
on the official level the hatred to
Christian Orthodox church to Russia. No
one. There are some salafi radical
tendencies but we consider them to be
tool of Mossad and uh of CIA and normal
Islam. Traditional Islam outside of
Russia is considered to be very friendly
and ally uh societies. Uh cons so that
is not about to to choose between Jews
or uh Muslims. We have no problem such
problem. But if Israel, not Jews, uh
Israel under uh under Netanyahu perhaps
uh itself like the murderous entity of
killing the people, striking the
innocent innocent children to killing
the chief of sovereign Iran state of
Iran. We could not support that. We we
are against it by by human uh
considerations by our our feeling or or
what justices not is not about to choose
between Islam or or Judaism. We consider
Judaism absolutely legitimate normal
religious tradition. But when we see
behavior of radical far-right Zionist we
are against that. And when we see what
what role they play in uh trying to
secure the global domination of the
west, we we could not we could not
respect them. So we we understand that
they exist. We are dealing realistically
with them. We don't blame them as such
but we very severely reject their mode
of uh of behavior. So we are against
genocide of people in Gaza. We are in
favor of the suffering Palestinians. We
are in favor of the uh Lebanese fighting
for their freedom and justice and their
fatherlands. We are totally supporting
Iran in this just war. uh but we we we
not support we don't support Iran
against for example uh uh United uh
Emirates or against the Qatar or against
Saudi Arabia we we um we want to stop
this war we don't choose between Shia
and Sunni we consider Muslim world as
our potential great great partner and
friend uh but when our friends are
attacked severely and unjust uh without
any justice. So we normally we come to
to hell that is normal behavior realist
behavior there is nothing religious
religious in that but at the same time
interesting that our realist
geopolitical behavior coincides
somehow with the uh end time agenda that
that is the kind of paradox. So we could
uh evaluate we could describe what is
going on in Middle East in the same time
uh by two different layers of reality.
the normal geopolitics, realistic
uh realistic calculation and some
international norms that Russia defends
in spite of all and at the same time we
could uh we could merge that we could
project that on the geography of of the
end of the time the geography of the
prophecy and they now they coincide
almost perfectly. that is very unique
moment. So when uh the uh everyday
reality start to to intermingle with uh
the metaphysical esqueological alliance
and that is very very special.
>> Right. I want to get to Ukraine war with
Russia here. But uh first I want to see
Professor Jen if you have any major
points of contention with Professor
Dugan and maybe Russia in general. If
Alexander Dugan actually is the brains
behind modern Russia, what is your major
grievance with the modern Russian Empire
or anything that Alexander Dugan has
said so far or from what you've seen
beforehand?
>> Right. So I have quite a few questions.
Um, my first question is I don't really
fully understand the concept of the
catacon, right? Because the catacon is
the force that keeps the antichrist at
bay. But if the antichrist system is
arising
and it is going to consume the world
anyway, my question is why stop it
rather than just let it consume the
world um and then from that seek
salvation and redemption like like I
don't I really don't understand the
concept of of the catacon.
>> So thank you that that is very deep
question. First of all, Catacon it is
traditional Christian Orthodox tra uh
concept and it is linked not only to the
church but to the state as well. So the
catacon was considered to be the Rome
Roman Empire and in our case we consider
ourselves to be the hairs of the
Byzantine Empire after its fall and so
served Rome. So our role on the global
map of the end of the time uh it is
cataconic. It is catacon to be to play
the role of the sacred Christian
Orthodox empire or state sacred state
empire in the in the sense of the secret
state secret political entity in order
to prevent the coming of antichrist. And
you you you put right and there are many
texts of Agamban of
other author following Carl Schmidt who
has introduced the concept of Katakon
and uh political science
uh and Talbes as well Jewish author
about western esquetology. Very
interesting. They they uh have
formulated the same argument. If the
antichrist should come and he should so
why not to to get him rule its short
time in order to precipitate to
accelerate the second coming uh coming
of Christ. Why not? So that is the kind
of negative katon. So Katon delays
the antichrist fights again that not
letting it come and destroy everything
and uh proceed to hassen to accelerate
uh second coming. So on the
philosophical level we could we could
accept that but morally morally we have
uh in our special katonic
cataconic ethics the tradition. So you
should always state with truth and never
let the evil and the lie to enter in the
world until the last moment. So uh you
you should not accelerate or let the
time to be accelerated. If it is
necessary you should delay them. If
necessary um you should be killed on the
catechonic path. So but not let the evil
come in. So that is very very special
moral attitude. So never side with the
evil. never including when the evil is
necessary maybe maybe for God's God's
plans but we have our our mission here
in in the world and the history stay
against uh antichrist until the last
breath. So that is kind of cataconic
ethics and that is perceived very deeply
by our society by by our government. So
uh in spite of all other considerations
we should accomplish our mission. Maybe
we it will it will bring us to our end
our death. But death cataconic death it
is the uh the duty the spiritual
historical sacred duty of Russian of
Russian people. And now we consider more
and more the modern abstain west to be
antichrist. So our mission is uh is
acquiring now uh the the new dimension.
For example, we stand we stood we stood
against Catholicism. We stood against
Protestantism but we still we we still
were inside of Christianity. So one
branch of Christianity, our branch, your
branch. But now it is not about one one
branch of Christianity against the
other. That is abstain globalist totally
posthuman post capitalist perverted
western civilization. It is pure
antichrist. It is not just suggestion
just just uh presumption that maybe the
west is wrong. Maybe western
Christianity is not sole secret as our
Christian Orthodox church. It it was in
the history just presumption just just
consideration. And now before our eyes
the the whale is taken off and we see
this three millions it's enough. Maybe
there are uh more three millions of
Epstein files. But we need we see now
the real reality real face of western
ruling elite not only only left liberals
as well right. So both it is UD party
that is it is not just left left
globalism as we presumed. how we see as
well the path of of the right the
Zionist the some other people in the
same in in in the same network obstain
network. I I have spoken recently with
Ian
uh with one bishop Christian Orthodox
and he has said uh um considering or
reading Epstein
files we uh remember we are reminded
about or what our elders spiritual
states spiritual authorities wrote
during all last decades about the real
nature of the west and this young bishop
he has said we
we didn't we didn't believe too much we
we thought that it is some exaggeration
mystical vision maybe the west is not
like that and now watching uh seeing
epines
we we see that our elders authorities uh
affirming affirming that the west is
modern west is antichrist were
absolutely right and this big confir
religious confirmation. So epstein files
are much more than just sexual scandal
or sex trafficking some something much
more important that is very very
persuasive esqueological sign that is
read by civilizations by humanity. If
you are like that, if you tolerate that
and zero arrests after all, so there is
something wrong with you.
>> I was going to ask you that question if
you were going to say that the west is
basically the antichrist because the
catacon is the force resisting against
the coming of the antichrist.
Do you believe that two-part question is
the Katakon is that the Russian Empire
and does that just mean well going back
earlier I was asking you what are the
solutions for the American Empire right
now if we're becoming more delusioned
with this war or disillusion with this
war if people are wondering about the
Epstein files is in your view uh
professor Dugan is the American empire
strictly
antichrist evil
uh so it always depend. So our Christian
uh doctrine affirms that there is no
predestination there is the freedom we
profoundly believe in in freedom of the
human soul. So there are some
predisposition of history. There are
some coincidences in uh between politics
and the spiritual level of the reality.
But the human soul human being is always
free totally and absolutely free. So if
you follow if you choose to be
antichrist you are. If you continue to
go this this way it is up to you to
decide who who are you. We could not say
we uh for for for sure we observe the
signs of the beast uh in the western
modern modern politics in modern society
but we strongly believe in the
possibility to change everything to
change the nature of American society of
western society of modernity because
never never you will be antichrist
before you Say yes to antichrist before
you sign with uh antichrist the treaty
the covenant abstain covenant. Uh so if
you resist if we want the just to if you
want justice if you want to follow
different uh different road different
path you always can change everything.
So it is about you to accept the role of
antichrist or reject. And when Trump
started his second term campaign
uh for for for voting campaign, we have
uh we have seen we have remarked some uh
signs of reversal of this situation and
we believe that that we believed in
American waters in American people in
American Trumpists because they they
they have shown the to overcome this uh
insane globalist walk uh perverted
um culture, cancel culture, globalism
and concentrate they promise to
concentrate on domestic domestic uh
affairs and to restore traditional
values. And we we we have decided maybe
there the God has given the American
people one chance more because you are
never antichrist will come if you not
welcome him if you not call for him if
if you not if you don't invite him
previously. So in order to be possessed
by a demon you should say yes come in
you are welcome enter in myself. But if
uh enough people in America and I
believe there are many millions maybe
maybe tens of millions of normal
American people who don't don't uh
welcome uh invite antichrist in
themselves and we are in total
solidarity with American people. So you
can be just anti-Christian West or you
can be humanity, you could be your own
society, could be the real real humans
uh who choose to stay human to defend
the spiritual identity and your your
roots your your deep tradition and in
that case you could avoid that. So and
we will uh change uh as well our our
predictions or uh postpone them or delay
them or everything depends on the human
soul uh immortal human soul and human
heart.
>> One more short followup question before
I go to professor Jen. What was the
meeting with Putin and Epstein about?
Because to push back a little, you you
are placing all the blame on the Epstein
files on America, which is, you know,
it's all over the Epstein files. He did
live in Manhattan and he had a resort in
Palm Beach, Florida, one in New Mexico,
and he has ties with the American
government, but he also seemed to have
some sort of Russian connection.
Obviously, that's overstated in the
media. People like Piers Morgan did try
to insinuate that he was a Russian spy,
which is blatantly ignoring all the
connections he has with Trump, with Wall
Street, with the Rothschilds, and with
so many people in American financial and
political elite. What was the
relationship with Putin and Epstein?
So uh to say the truth uh I presume that
some quantity of Russian oligarchs and
maybe um the the part um not to big part
but part of Russian elites had some
connections with abstain network and we
need to to study that to because uh when
we tried to unite with the west and when
uh our government in '90s above all
declared that we Russia we are just the
part of the west this uh kind of
convergency between western society and
Russian economical political elites
started as well. So the communication
between
special services, the oligarchs, they
they shared their common yaks, they they
common common castles and uh there are
some cases already investigated in in
Russian. the connections the connections
of some people of Russia inside of uh
abstain abstain class because it is
universal but because the west uh wanted
to be something universal. We see uh
among abstain people, the people from
Arab world uh the rich uh rich um
monarchs or the people of royal family
at least. So we see as well there some
Russian oligarchs and that is plague
that is a kind of a kind of toxic
ambulance or illness sickness
uh that uh
that was distributed
through different different societies in
Europe in in America and Middle East and
it affected Russia and Poland and other
other other countries. So, but uh the
measure the measure uh of Russian
involvement uh in abstaining class is
relatively small not to speak about
manipulation. We see clearly that is
Roel's family behind Mosad behind the
very deep connections with
uh CIA and other secret services of the
west. But uh it is absolutely impossible
to uh KGB to manipulate uh abstain class
because the west is dealing with the
the phantom pain about KGB. The modern
KGB is is called FSB. It's totally
different. So it could not it could not
dare to to to start something like that.
It is totally defensive. It is on
defensive defensive not maybe it is not
so good. I would prefer to fsbe to act
more proactively not just reaction but
we have what we have we have this
defensive attitude toward the west and
that is all. So to to the idea that
Russian modern
be capable to manipulate the whole west
it is uh the myth of the cold war. So uh
that belongs to totally different epoch.
It is absolutely nonrealistic concerning
modern day Russia. Russia is just in the
first stage of of uh revival. We just
just become
serious normal. We we were totally out
uh uh out of rand totally uh totally
confused uh during last 30 years. So we
just coming into focus with the with the
reality. We were paralyzed uh and
seduced by the west and now we we are
coming to our deep deep identity and
roots and we were totally incapable to
to manage such huge and and evil thing
as abstain class.
>> Okay. Professor Jen, are there any
disagreements you have? And what is your
perception of what Professor Dugan just
said about the relationship that the
West has with the Antichrist?
Um
um I mean I I agree overall
that um western civilization is based on
certain
ideas
that are antihuman. For example,
um the idea of
individuality,
um the idea of rationality,
which is the basis of science, um the
and the idea of consumerism,
um you you know, utilitarianism. I think
that these um ideas
have um diverged from the classical
humanistic um tradition and which is the
cause of so much misery and discontent
in the world. So people just assume that
the enlightenment, the sonic revolution
marked this incredible revolution in
human affairs and it's what's led to
globalization,
uh the internet, um tremendous wealth
creation,
um you know, space travel. But at the
same time we have to look at human
psychology and how miserable people are
and how hopeless uh and helpless people
feel uh nowadays. And this this is an
idea that I've been struggling with um a
long long time. But I think that where
Professor Dugan and I will have some
differences is that
um for a lot of people this system is
extremely attractive and they will fight
to the death to maintain this system. So
I I feel that in Russia um there's just
more urgency um to fight the antichrist
but
um maybe in more materialistic societies
such as China.
Um it's really a question of like how do
you maintain this system because it's
brought so much happiness and prosperity
to so many people right so Chinese like
to say that um after China opened up to
the world um billions of people were
lifted out of poverty so you've never
seen before so much wealth creation so I
wonder um how attractive
this um idea of the antichrist um and
trying to stop the antich Christ, how
how attractive it is to people. I wonder
if given a choice, how many people
people will will choose to resist? Um
and
um yeah,
how many people choose to resist? So I
think you do point out the despair,
underlying despair, not to make it doom
and gloom, but many people are feeling
exactly what you just described. I just
did a a podcast with Bradley Martin
yesterday and he was saying how
exhausted he feels now and he reminded
me of the last stream we did, Professor
Jang, where we both agreed that the new
strategy seems to not be blatant
censorship but flooding an algorithm
with tons of information all at once.
So, the truth is out there more than it
ever has been. It's been readily
available, but it's mixed up with so
much anger and negative discourse that
people feel drained just looking at it.
And so, the new tactic is not to
blatantly censor, but to flood with so
much information that you don't have the
energy to care. I think the Lebanon
phenomenon is a perfect example where we
just finished seeing the genocide in
Gaza happen. So now that you see a
million people displaced in Lebanon, you
see villages wiped out. So many people
in America just don't have the energy to
even care. They used to care about Epste
and then he became a meme. Maybe that
was intelligence agency pushing this to
try to normalize it. But people have too
many things at once to care about. Not
only that, in their personal lives, they
have to care about their job. They have
to care about their debt. What do you
think are the solutions? How do we push
us in the right direction? because it's
too defeist, I believe, to just
blatantly say the West is the Antichrist
and there's no actual way out. There's
got to be some light at the end of the
tunnel. Correct.
>> I I I think having these sort of debates
and discussions is really key. Um so I
really enjoyed hearing Professor Dugan's
perspective. So, thank you so much,
Sneo, for setting setting this up, you
know, um you know, and and I'm really
sympathetic towards his his viewpoints.
And I feel, you know, rather than just
name callings and saying, you know, I'm
a CCC spy and Professor Dugan is a KGB
spy, even though the KGB does doesn't
exist anymore. Um, I think it's really
important to have these transnational,
you know, international conversations
where different perspectives are brought
together and and where um there's
rigorous debate. And unfortunately you
know um people are so used to name
calling. People are so used to ad
hominant attacks and we have to return
to a tradition where um ideas are given
the proper space to flourish and you do
that by engaging in debate and
discussion with people who you don't
agree with but who are open to um debate
and discussion.
>> Absolutely. I think this was uh it's
pretty interesting. This panel has a lot
of different perspectives and although
we perhaps could have went a little more
into esquetology, we did cover a lot of
the points in the PowerPoint. I think we
there was a good summary of a lot of
different world events and what's
happening around, you know, if you're
representing Russia, uh if you're
representing China and over here if I'm
representing America or Islam, whatever
people want to say. I think this was a
very interesting dialogue and I I
appreciate the both of you for coming on
and I I look forward to to having more.
>> Yeah. I mean I mean Yeah. Sorry. Sorry.
Go ahead.
>> Professor Please, please.
>> I sorry. Uh uh I would like to only to
point out maybe to to respond to what
Mr. Junk has said. So obviously there is
the huge amount of people in China or in
Russia who would prefer material
material prosperity to the white for
katahun. Uh and that was always the case
and when Christ came the absolute
majority was involved in the everyday
matters and were the same way with Noah.
Noah uh uh with deluj with a flute plot.
So that is normal but uh that was not
material in interest that govern the
history. History uh obtains its meaning
when it comes to the ideas and their
ideas could be ignored by the people and
the people prefer normal everyday life
to these ideas to but they are living in
the illusion and Hegel Hegel called that
uh the trick of the uh universal reason,
universal intellect. He is promoting the
spiritual and agenda of ideas who really
rule the history and the humankind, the
humanity play here the role but without
knowing. So I I think that idea to
defend Katakon is uh understood by small
small minority of modern Russian. We are
spoken speaking about that Putin know
that that some elite spiritual
scientific elite know that but that's
all but in spite of that all our history
was moved by this catonic function
function in cataconic mission in spite
in spite of the people and the people
are materialist but the history is not
the history it is the logic of of of
divine in providence and uh the same I
think. So if we ask Russian people maybe
they would prefer the west the comfort
the western values and maybe some
negative western uh values for example
individualism and so on and if we ask
some American people maybe they will
choose spiritual
vice versa. So that is about the
freedom. Freedom for you but freedom for
us. We could say yes to katonic mission
in consciously or consciously and we
could say no we prefer to be
abstain civilization. Maybe we'll will
not be eaten finally and we will be uh
among those who were invited to uh to
eat uh children. So uh it is uh just
hope of of the people of of of the
humanity of the society and this
decision is always always free and that
I think is the chance for America. So uh
if you prefer to be on the side of God,
you will decide with your demonic elite
and you will uh you will yourself
uh will deal with this satanic
anti-Christian elite because because it
is not about the majority of normal, the
good and just American people. It is
just about hijacking your idea,
hijacking your your soul and pushing it
into the abyss. It is not your choice.
It is just the violence against you. And
the same violence we feel by this
materialism but the attraction to the
worldly worldly worldly values in spite
of the spiritual values. I think
something like that. Maybe here I'm not
expert. Maybe something like that we
could trace as well in Chinese society
because accepting so many aspects of
western civilization
maybe China is somehow undermines
its own traditional values. So we see
this huge I mean perfect technologically
perfect incredible futuristic cities
with uh no no children on the street. So
the the people are individualistic. They
are prosperous. They are Chinese. They
they are proud to be Chinese patriots.
So they they share totally this the
common common ideas but they are they
are lost some sometimes psychologically
lost because the west is toxic somehow.
So you could accept and transform
trans sub transubstance some uh elements
of this uh western materialist and
capitalist poison. But there are some
measure and if you overcome it uh the
situation could be bit different. So I
have the great hope in Chinese culture
and Chinese future that is amazing
amazing how you could uh how you how you
could uh combine the traditional values
with material technological prosperity.
It is amazing that that is something
that is miracle. So I admire that. But I
I I can see that maybe it will be moment
to pay for that. So if you take too much
poison, it will affect you sooner or
later. But it is up to you to decide the
measure and I think that is totally you
are free too. Chinese are free.
Americans are free. Russian a free
Muslim
are totally free. You can say I am for
that. You can I accept, you can say I
deny and nobody could uh uh or oblig us
to make not free decision.
>> That was my favorite point of yours
today. Uh Professor Dugan saying that
it's up to you to allow the demon to
enter. I think that's a important fact
to remember. Thank you so much to the
both of you for coming on. I greatly
appreciate this conversation.
and Professor Jen, tomorrow we're
supposed to speak with uh Professor
Morandi, correct?
>> Yep. Yep. Absolutely. So, so what time?
>> I
don't hear the confirmation from him
yet. I I need to check. I'll make sure
to email it to you. I know it's very
late over there in Beijing. It's about
uh it's like almost 11 p.m. for you,
right?
>> Uh yes, that's right. Yes.
>> So, yeah, he I still need to hear the
response from him. I'll try to get it
around the same time. So, probably
morning for you is better. So yeah, Iran
time is a little bit different. What
time is it in? Are you in Moscow,
Professor Dugan?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. So it must be very late over
there.
>> 6:00 uh 6:00. Uh and in I presume in
Iran there is uh uh seven and a half
something like that now.
>> So I I'll try to get it. And if
Professor Morandi can't come, would you
like to speak to Dave Smith?
>> Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, I mean he trying
to prevent Dave Smith. I mean like like
Yeah, sure.
>> Okay. So, that will I'll I'll message
both of them and I'll I'll email you.
Hope you get some rest. Thank you so
much. Uh this was a great conversation
and I'll speak to you guys soon. Thank
you. God bless.
>> Okay. Bye.
>> Bye.
>> Bye. Bye.
>> Thank you so much. Baby, can't you hear
my call?